ciao a tutti leggendo i commenti che mi
vengono spesso lasciati sotto i miei
imbarazzantissimo i video leggo spesso
questa cosa ma che infanzia ha avuto per
uscire così brutti insensibili diciamo
che ho avuto un'infanzia travagliata una
infanzia orribile è un bambino difficile
con diciamo che era un bambino difficile
anzi ero completamente scollato dalla
realtà e oltre essere scollata dalla
realtà
non sapevo bene cosa fosse figo e cosa
non fosse figo ero fondamentalmente è
uno sfigato un imbarazzante scherzo
della natura che con la crescita è
solamente peggiorata parlami
c'è detto parlarmi cosa cosa ami ti
prego parlami
va bene si sogni e non mi potete vedere
o non sono state ne sono ma qui c'è un
camionista mattino non ce l'ho io sì ti
prego
poi non ti preoccupare se tutto era
ritrovare la via di casa sono un tuo
amico
qui è tutto incappato ma che è quello
katia ok ho deciso gonfi due palloncini
e particolari casa per le medie ed entro
quest anno fa dice un enorme gatto blu e
io lo voglio abbracciare coraggio parti
ti servono le chiavi cretino
arti o che non era proprio di questo che
volevo parlare volevo parla di altre
cose
volevo infatti parlare di diversi tipi
di lavoro che esistono esistono fra
stato
chi è
l'avete voluto voi americani
[Musica]
oggi
questo diavolo di sciacca face
l'evangelo salviamo facebook
questo diavolo di shogun place lo sai
diamo facebook
ed è proprio così che ho visto primi 20
minuti il cars 2 se ci stiamo credendo
no comunque volte ci penso per tornare
un attimo all'idea del lavoro ecco
ideale ecco immaginatevi tipo lavorare
alla pixar di tipo il pezzo il sogno di
chiunque anche se riflettendo c'è un
secondo penso che se io fossi il regista
di cars 2 molto probabilmente il mio
cars 2 sarebbe stata una versione un po
diversa tipo così il che mi fa
ringraziare il cielo di non essere il
regista di questo film
comunque a parte gli scherzi se siete
curiosi di sapere di più della mia
esperienza san francisco cliccate sul
riquadro segreto alla fine del video io
vi saluto e vi lascio con una cosa molto
bella che ha detto john lassater nella
chiacchierata in è stata permessa di
fare con lui
penso che possa essere forse uno degli
auguri e di consigli migliori da dare
una persona ciao action mais hans kelsen
sempre voluto pazzo di tihar cazzola che
si è scheggiato ma no ma dio sa cosa
dice perché spagnolo e poi ebbe andando
a sole gli scan a cui è principio ne
seguì a chi e ne andai amico e nemico lo
spagnolo
[Musica]